it was 1972 love was in the air and a
pair of scientists made a discovery that
serendipitously made them legends in the
pride movement
[Music]
meet Siebert biologists and
oceanographer George hunt
hi I'm George hunt and his partner at
the time Molly I'm Molly Warner in 1972
they were doing research on the behavior
of Western gulls off the coast of Santa
Barbara
one day Molly called me to let me know
she'd found something really unexpected
we had to mark territories and nests to
look at how the eggs were laid and we
found extra eggs than we expected this
shocking discovery puzzled them somehow
these nests had more eggs than a single
female could lay per day direction of
the study switched to try and figure out
what was going on over the next year and
a half they spent more time with these
goals and discovered two female birds
were acting as a mated pair they shared
a nest and raise their young together to
our knowledge this was the first
instance of homosexuality in a wild
population they went on to publish their
findings in an international scientific
journal the response was overwhelming
I had phone calls from New York Times
Times of India London Times one of the
Australian newspapers and it even ended
up in places like Playboy unfortunately
there was a lot of backlash to
homosexuality in 1970s America was still
misunderstood people felt angry toward
us and the research we did and they even
worked hard to try and get Congress to
slow down the funding it was a strange
time in seagull research but then
something else happened farmers started
to send letters to faint said if I spend
any time on a farm I would know that
farm animals are often the same sex lady
turns out their findings were not all
that radical today hundreds of different
animal species have been found exhibit
homosexual behavior it was natural it
had a really big impact on the arguments
against homosexuality that said it
doesn't occur in nature and therefore is
against God's will
the homosexual pairing has very little
to do with morality as far as the gulls
are concerned George and Molly received
letters postcards and phone calls from
members of the LGBT community thanking
them for their bravery this research
transcended into music cartoons and even
plays that's the best you can hope for
in science is that a piece of work is
used by other scientists and a really
big bonus is if it makes a difference to
the people of a nation that's supported
[Music]